for the most part the very young have
been spared the devastating effects of
covert 19 but there are tragic
exceptions and in the united states
covet is blamed for hundreds of deaths
of children under the age of five an age
category that's not currently eligible
for vaccines that's likely to change
very soon based on clinical trials by
the pharmaceutical giant pfizer which
included three doses administered to
almost 1700 recipients over several
months
in a statement pfizer says our
formulation for the youngest children
which we carefully selected to be one
tenth of the dose strength for adults
was well tolerated and produced a strong
immune response
pfizer and his partner bioentech plan to
take their findings to u.s regulators
this week claiming the new vaccine is 80
effective the risks are minute the
benefits might be small given the fact
that the pandemic is waning to some
extent and the and the threat posted
children is somewhat small compared to
adults
but the comparing the two vaccine
absolutely outweighs the risk
epidemiologist ray watt deonandum
believes the vaccine will also remove
the fear factor for parents of very
young children
parents like him if my kid for example
is going to day care in september
i'm pretty confident now that he'll have
some strong immunity when he goes to
daycare in the fall that's that's
exciting if approved by government
regulators the vaccine will fill a big
gap out of 85 million doses administered
in canada vaccination coverage is
highest in adults aged 60 and older at
almost 94 percent fully vaccinated
canadians between 12 and 60 are also
well protected in the mid to high 80s
there's a big drop to 42 percent for
younger children the under 5 category is
virtually empty with no approved vaccine
more than two years after the pandemic
started
regulatory approval could come within
days adding to pfizer's nearly 37
billion u.s dollars in covet vaccine
sales and adding another layer of safety
as the pandemic drags on
ross lord global news